Let's go next
to our callers from the eight oh five area
code.
Who's calling today from eight oh five.
Hello? Yes.
It sounds like you are both on speaker and
at a bowling alley.
Can you hear me at all?
I am, yeah.
I'm so sorry.
I was on, on both Caribbean.
You're on a boat trip.
You're on a bus.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
So can you hear me?
Probably
I can sort of hear you.
Yes.
What's on your mind today?
Hey, so, um, I'm just, uh, I'm calling to
ask kind of like a kind of a tactical question
about kind of like how the Democrats should
kind of navigate 20 [inaudible].
I know that recently there's kind of, there's
kind of like, like, um, I know recently destiny
made a video where he kind of, he stated that
that kind of working to like run like congressional
candidates that um, congressional candidates
that don't use corporate pac money and don't
really own that are kind of uncorrupted.
It's kind of a very privileged, like it's
kind of a very privileged position to come
from.
It's kind of taking a, a, you're taking a
stance that's like, um, that you're kind of
fucked.
You're prioritizing like a very kind of like
an asks back like principle of purity over
like the wellbeing of people who are most
like not effected by the political deck.
Okay.
And I was just wondering, um, like do you
think that that there is value in like can
we really justify trying to run candidates
on without corporate tax money like uncropped
candidate if it results in it with all them
more Republicans winning like
very good.
Yes.
I think I got it.
Listen, um, I think that the short, I haven't
seen the commentary you mentioning, but in
short, I think that not accepting corporate
pac money is a great thing and I hope it becomes
the new normal.
I do think that, um, if it's going to cost
you seats then we have to question what is
it that it is going to help us achieve if
we are literally losing to Republicans as
a result of doing it.
But it's just, it's so crazy where you are
that I'm going to let you go.
Maybe you can call back with a better connection
at some point because it just, I hope you're
not driving the bus.
I hope you're just on the bus cause it sounds
like it is really, really chaotic there.
Let me go to our caller from the five, six
two area code.
Who's calling today from five, six two.
Okay.
Yes ma'am.
That's you.
Yeah.
And what, what's going on with your phone?
Yes.
Oh, sorry.
What do you mean?
Uh, I don't know it, it sounds like you're
talking through a pillow.
That's really weird.
What did your city better right now?
It's marginally better.
Yeah.
What's your, what's your question?
Okay.
Um, okay, so my question here is,
okay, but now I know your voice has changed.
Is this the same person or did you hand the
phone to somebody else
on the phone to somebody else?
Okay.
No, I'm, I'm hearing myself on a three second
delay.
I got to bail out.
I'm sorry.
It sounds like you're listening to this on,
on we, we, we've got 63 people holding.
I, I just, I can't deal with that right now.
I apologize.